and I'm delighted to be here I hope you
guys all had a good first day and good
dinner it's hard to always talk after
people eat but like Linda said I hope
you drank some caffeine you're gonna eat
the good chocolate maybe that'll keep
you up um so about me and then I'm gonna
ask you guys a few questions
um so I did go to business school on
East Coast they didn't let me in here or
I would have come it's been a few years
at Microsoft that was fun that I came
here and I was a full-time general
partner at Kleiner Perkins for over a
decade and led on 20-some i deals there
and then a few years ago i decided to
sort of phase out of that so now i'm
doing a variety of things i class here
which some of these slides will be
directly from the curriculum and i still
on a few choir boards and do a lot of
angel investing i've invested in 13
startups of my own money of the last few
years on my own salts or a lot of you
know about so that's me so obviously i
don't i'm not going to get to know all
of you at this level detail but at some
level of evil I am I make sure you so
show of hands how many people have been
more than five years removed from from
GSB okay and how many have either
started a business before or after
school how many ones go to business now
I'm not not that surprised by that
all right so I was asked to talk about
this topic evaluating a business idea
and having been both a general manager
and vice president of Microsoft we
thought about evaluate businesses in one
way and then as an institutional that's
capless another way and now as an angel
investor yet another way although I've
never been an entrepreneur per se and so
I had to think twice before I really
because I've never really done a
presentation on this topic specifically
so I had to think a couple of times
about it and the question that came to
mind is you know how do you judge a
business idea and you know there's some
sort of standard tricks of the trade and
we'll talk about them but I got I wanted
to get more fundamental I mean how do
you how to decide on what metrics to
judge a business and I thought you know
a similar question in some regards is
how do you know you're happy it's a very
personal decision and everybody has a
different set of what I call ways to
measure what happiness or you know what
a successful business idea so I want to
start this by you know kind of going a
little out of the box for second because
I think a lot of you probably can do
this thinking you know hey this guy's
offense capitalist he's going to give us
you know some like market sizing you
know multiples how exciting the business
opportunities and we'll get to that but
I think I want to start by saying you
know most businesses 99.9% of all
business we got started in the world but
certainly even the United States are not
venture capital funded businesses so I
think I want to sort of draw a little
cast a wider net when we think about
this topic so here's my high way of
thinking about this and this is not this
is no science you know bridges
textbook but I put up a bunch of
possible outcomes just to give you some
food for thought when you think about if
I immediate isn't and you know some
people are very satisfied to run what I
call lifestyle businesses you know they
throw up a lot of cash some of them not
all the some of them do they're never
going to go public they're never going
to get a great multiple than every a
venture capitalist excited but they're
perfectly good businesses you know it
used to be maybe not lately but a long
time we have the rich people in your
town where the people owned the car
dealerships those are great lifestyle
businesses right they screw up cash you
know you've had a franchise
you're really not threatened now
obviously it didn't last forever but but
for many years that was a great business
to um another kind of idea you know for
some people is actually to go into the
social service sector of a nonprofit
sector and they're not going to be
measured on profits they may not be
measured on growth they might be
measured on social movement you know and
more and more like I actually was at
this institution today as a gas in a
case for a GSB class about a nonprofit
that I'm the board chair up and one of
the points I made to the class as a gas
was the case was about should as a
nonprofit grow or not
and I said growth in nonprofits in
certain sectors of the nonprofit world
are you have to think about differently
than businesses that their growth should
not be measured by our revenues or
people or profits or property is to be
measured on can they grow their impact
you know so again I don't know what your
your measure is for success but I want
you to think you know it's not just the
lack you know in the Silicon Valley kind
of real you everybody thinks that you
know what you want to do when you start
a company is you raise venture capital
and shoot to the moon and you know what
once in a while that happens most times
so I found this cartoon that I think
sort of speaks to this theme builders
like my favorite cartoons by far so this
is dauber in his usual consulting mode
and he says you can remind the
entrepreneurial spirit here by reminding
people of the early years he points a
picture
he says your founders were two bums who
began in a hardware box that he says one
bum this style is boogie and
accidentally bought Cisco stock at the
IPO now not when you would consider a
traditional success story but maybe for
some people this might be a success
story located by the way if you can do
that actually good good for you most
people can't do that
but again the spirit of this is I think
you have to measure your own success
metrics and just because you're in the
valley and like there's so many people
who've left Stanford and started places
like Google good for them but it's not
for everybody and most times that's not
the story that people are going to get
edited by so now I'm kind of where I'll
go for the next bunch of slides here is
to talk about kind of some of the tricks
of the trade as I mentioned earlier that
people use to evaluate business
opportunities now one that you probably
learned if you're graduate of this place
business idea Five Forces even I was
Papa's it's go a long time ago this
thing it's good you know people still
use it I mean I think consultants to use
it but to be honest with you when it
comes to using this tool for evaluating
entrepreneurial opportunities
that's not very it's not very useful
because you look at these things you
know you're supposed to know like who
the suppliers and how powerful they're
going to be and what the substitutes are
when you're when you're using when
you're thinking about a startup
opportunity
since extension it's you know usually
now there you know you could be a late
entrant some of this might be present
but the most part you know a frame like
this a framework like this well it's
great in evaluating businesses that
operate in industry sectors but are well
understood for most startups certainly
the kind that I look at as an investor
both institutionally and as an angel
investor this doesn't really help you
very much so you can think about it you
can you know think about where you might
end up if the company is successful but
most of this doesn't really make any
sense for start-up at the beginning so
another important thing to think about
you know I again a very typical kind of
thing that people throw each people when
they're thinking about evaluating this
opportunities is the strength of the
team me because you don't know about the
future but you know what's here today is
often the team starting team and one
thing they teach a lot I think these
days it wasn't as big a deal actually
when when I went through business school
is this idea entrepreneur authenticity
what does that mean I put it in quotes
because I'm not really sure everybody
kind of views it the same way but I
think I think the notion is that people
who have who are starting these
companies if they have real-world
experience knowledge if they've
internalized the problem in a weak way
that's really authentic that's that's
that's an interesting place to start an
evaluation of a business opportunity in
other words you know how does how does
the problem come to manifest itself how
does the opportunity to manifest itself
it usually comes from the entrepreneur
that's actually I can occur at dinner it
doesn't mean you have to have lived in
the industry that you want to start a
company what it means is that you have
internalized a problem you become an
expert to the degree that you can
credibly and authentically talk about
the problem and the solution you're
you're providing so I think that is a
place to start but it it has to be
augmented often by sort of the idea that
who else can you recruit what other
advisors or team members have been
treated by the Platon team and then I
think the last thing is probably equally
important to me anyway one of the things
I look at when I think about a violating
a business idea is what motivates the
team and I'll tell you we have this
thing in kleiner and I think a lot of
its capitals have this is that um you
sometimes would have a team come in and
they need not doing a presentation and
within you know few slides you know the
whole idea of selling the company and
what the returns were going to be I mean
look everybody knows that investors are
in it for some kind of return but
there's a certain kind of presentation a
sort of kind of entrepreneur that really
comes on with the sort of bum mentality
that it's it's all about making money
and that really turned me off and it
really typically turns off like client
or other a lot of other institutional
councils because that kind of mentality
it it doesn't speak to the staying power
and the passion of the entrepreneurs
what really sort of I think is the thing
that when you're looking at a founding
team you really really get excited about
it's what motivates them is usually the
mission their passion for the idea their
passion for the you know the what the
product or the service is going to do
not necessarily what the out now
everybody wants a good financial outcome
but that's that's sort of a byproduct
what really motivates and really what
what a really great entrepreneurial
opportunity looks like typically is a
very passionate motivated so that's
certainly in terms of evaluating
opportunities that that's where one of
the places I start now another thing a
lot of people will have you think about
when you think about evaluating
opportunities for startups is you know
what trends are coming along that you
know you can run
it's certainly a lot of businesses
especially the technology area to get
sort of successful or maybe sometimes
not successful because they arrived
these ways so I just listed a few of
them I mean there there's some that are
obvious that rise you know all boats or
for singsong voice which is sort of a
natural economic things you know
recessions inflation but they're much
more interesting ones to look at like
technology disruption like like these
platforms like iPhone that come along
you know before you know it you have
like 10 million people using a device it
didn't use a few years ago that's an
interesting thing as a start-up to think
hard about how you parlay that into some
advantage how do you take advantage of
that I think the stuff is going on in
healthcare reform right now there is
gone throwing so many opportunities
around that we've yet to understand and
I know I'm sure the people in the health
services area investors and
entrepreneurs are already starting to
stiff goes out so at any one time any of
these trends could be you know really
real and and important to start
businesses but you have to be careful
because some of them can be ephemeral
they can come and go like you know aging
for example aging surreal a real trend
and a lot of people have been trying to
build businesses around aging for a long
time I first got decliner for 13 14
years ago I started seeing some of those
plan here we are 14 years later I'm not
sure that that was a trend that on 14
years ago maybe it is now but you know
tightening is very relevant to start out
and so these trends sometimes you know
the timing of them is not always obvious
so another sort of dimension when you
think about evaluating these
opportunities and evaluating any one is
and again this is just kind of the
landscape and it's hard to kind of pin
down what innovation is but I sort of
tried to sort of create a couple of
buckets here one one that the kind of
[ __ ] capitals that I was and still am
some degree as an angel is is this first
button which is build a better mousetrap
you know a product innovation and they
come in the venture world there's sort
of two different kinds that people talk
about one is brave new world and the
other is better faster cheaper better
faster cheaper it's kind of easy to
understand it's basically there's a
product already in the market team comes
in and says hey I got a better way to
build it either faster cheaper you know
it's a different kind of investment
typically you know it's not a home run
but you can often make pretty good money
doing that a lot of the the team's
authenticity and knowledge comes to bear
right because they sort of say I know
exactly what the current product in the
market is and how we're going to build
something back so plenty of investments
have done have been done on that sort of
theme but the ones that most people like
particularly big institutional venture
capitalists are the brave new world ones
and I think this is kind of the ones
that I think a lot of young
entrepreneurs that come out please like
Stanford like to think about you know
groundbreaking something you know way
new product comes out of a lab at
Stanford or comes out of some research
that bet that the entrepreneur is
working on can be very exciting they
also have different risk reward
trade-offs right I mean the brave new
world ones often work a lot less than
the better faster cheaper ones but
sometimes the ones that the brave new
world ones that do work have much more
upside so different kinds of innovation
then there's business model innovation
and I think this is pretty interesting
because you know Google is an
interesting example you know people
don't actually know what the sort
traditional wisdom is about by Google
but we were investors in Google I helped
do the diligence on Google alignments
the first question board meetings and I
don't know do people think that Google
helps to show of hands if you think
Google is an innovative company or not
yet people think yes
ok you think what was innovative was
their technology their business the
technologies innovated yeah yeah yeah I
would argue otherwise I would argue
otherwise
and I'll tell you why because I think
yeah they had a better algorithm for
ranking technologies on the internet I'm
not really sure that's why users UOP
used certainly in the early days I think
what they used it for was because it was
more complete and it was faster and it
was a simpler UI and those things were
you know I don't know if that was huge
innovation but where I think the big
innovation was they and I'm not sure
they understood this in the early days
but what the reason Google is so super
successful if you read all these cases
about people have analyzed it is they
got a network effect going but getting
more users and therefore the advertisers
became more effective and when that
happened more users came and when that
happened more our positive can and so
forth that network effect was not
obvious in the early days in fact there
were no advertiser bohmian though it was
zero revenue we invested just because on
the traffic growth but in fact I would
claim that Google's biggest innovation
I'm sure somebody in the world might
challenge me and have better data but I
think their biggest innovation in a
sense was creating this network effect
around advertisers and search which
there have been lots of search companies
before then you know there was actually
when we invested in Google that was like
five or six but none of them had got
that flywheel going of advertisers and
users and that sort of tight loop that
Google still even now Microsoft support
hundreds of millions of dollars to try
to you know it'll eat your way up egg
Google's marcher and they still can
because they still have that now poor
fat going so I think one of the things
that's sort of maybe a little bit
appreciated finding opportunities out
there that you know it had some
innovation on the product or the
technology side but a lot of interesting
businesses get built around your
abilities network effects eBay people
don't realize Microsoft Windows is one
of the really big network effect
success stories the network effect there
was once you've trained all your people
to use Windows and Windows applications
it's really hard to stretch them so they
basically and even now I mean that what
people corporations and they don't
certainly go make the price but they
keep buying because all their all their
training manuals all their applications
I mean they're all so stuck in that
network with that so this is I think
underappreciated and a lot of times
people probably add institutions like
this I see though they want to start a
company the first thing they want to
tell me about is what product and the
technology that's interesting but I
think a lot of times I look at sort of a
business model innovation as well and
then there's just business execution
Dell figured out a way to sell computers
without retailers that was cool and now
they have retail but but you know and
Walmart figured out a way to have a
better distribution chain with lower
costs and all that stuff so those are
two jump some general themes now I'm
going to kind of go more specifically
into you have a specific idea you know
what are some of the rules of thumb and
and here's where this is a little bit
more kind of where you would see venture
capitalists or institutional investors
sort of thinking
along he's mine one of the things they
look for a lot is this idea between
product and market fit they teach that a
lot now this is close I think there's a
whole class here about this and the
whole idea is you know there's lots of
leaking market leads out there how do
you build a product really you know
feeds right into it and sort of drives
that kind of you know
excitement and fulfillment from the
customer that's a big thing and
understanding that fit and sort of how
the entrepreneurs see that fit and what
testing you can do early in your product
lifecycle to sort of prove to yourself
as an entrepreneur and to the investors
that there is a tight linkage between
the need and the product or service or
offering that's more like the probably
fundamental things that you have to look
for when you're evaluating a start-up
opportunity market size is obviously a
big deal I put sort of the rule of thumb
that venture capitalists look for you
know they typically and again it's
changed but you know I still rule of
thumb they like sort of a company then
gets 100 million dollar revenue and that
end 20 percent market share that implies
it kind of at least a 500 million dollar
market and of course lots of growth
typically you want to get in before
there isn't a 500 million dollar market
and you want to grow as it you know
becomes a $509 multi-billion dollar
market timing I mentioned it earlier but
timing is one of the sort of
underappreciated things both as an
author and as an investor because I have
seen so many interesting companies get
started but before their time and then a
few years later the same idea
team comes along and it's successful we
wonder why and it's because there's
market dynamics that just come to play
and sometimes you know great ideas just
are not gonna hit hit the sweet spot
sorry it's hard I mean you know I guess
I would say I think you don't know until
you're trying but what you don't want to
do is you don't want to over commit
spend a lot of money until you sort of
see that you are you have the right time
a lot of it is market risk you know that
so a lot of investors will say there's
four kinds of risk
there's product risk is market risk just
financial risk and there's a team risk
though his initial less Kappas like
kleiner would tell you don't worry about
a financial mess we have enough money we
help to raise money team risk we can
help you
you know mediate because we can help you
hire people or whatever product risk
we're willing to take product risk
that's what we do the big question is
market risk and so what you want to do
is you want to shake that down shake
that out as early in your process as
possible and you know now that I work
with angels I am with entrepreneurs and
angel investing my whole my I preach
them is look we don't know if this
products going to work one off the time
is right whatever but as long as we
don't over invest both terms of sweat
equity and in terms of money we will get
a modicum of a return I'll be someone
will buy it for something or will bow
and we'll feel okay about so at any
point of as where you go into it you
kind of have to realize that you don't
always know the answers but if you if
you kind of scale your investment
according to the data you get back you
feel
okay with competition obviously is it is
low competition is one of the things
that is attractive for a new business
but and sort of this kind of goes with
my comments about the Five Forces
there usually is no competition at the
beginning so it really you know the
question about competition more has to
do with barriers that we're going to
talk about also and then here's the last
thing that I don't know you know I'm
sure this is sort of traditional or you
know accepted wisdom but as an investor
one of the things I really appreciate
the what I call contrarian that's
because to me you know risk how the
reward goes with rest and if it's
obvious if it's if it's obvious what to
do if the business ideas are obvious a
products idea then all as obviously
customer needs like is obvious there's
only not a lot of upside of that I mean
even if you come across it first I'm
going to come across with soon
thereafter or probably at the same time
so to me I think sometimes the best bets
not await the time the best bets or the
ones that don't seem obvious in fact
later on kaalia that's obvious thinking
were not obvious but sometimes you'll
get to remember if it was that obviously
would have been done before so I think I
think the idea that that you know things
that don't seem obvious and might seem
really out of left field don't ignore
them now I'm not saying they're all
right but but there's I think a way as
an entrepreneur and as an investor to
think about those in a way that I think
potentially gets the good good good
outcomes so here's a question for you
guys
this 65-64 estimate now support million
or billion dollar question which wins a
poor market the great team we're a great
market with the poor team so who wants
to vote for a poor market with a great
team wins you know for market beats a
great team yep
well hands in the air let's see who
wants to choose the first object okay
okay so now you want to want to choose
the latter maybe maybe it's not it's a
divided crowd so I don't know what they
again it would be accepted wisdom is for
this I think a lot of people in the
investing business in Silicon Valley you
tell you great team I'm here to tell you
not true
I have seen unbelievable teams great
team go after a bad market you cannot
overcome a bad mark I'm not saying you
will fail every time but you will not
get a you know you will not get the best
you know the kind of outcome you're
looking for you you'll fill around
you'll maybe get something at it but you
know but I've also seen a very weak
teams participate in just astounding
market growth and have great success so
I would argue you know you want to have
great team there's and there's no reason
not to everything but make sure you're
participating in the great market
opportunity yeah
growing fast starting small and we're
going to go back yeah yeah yeah that's
that's well I mean then there's bill
business month question can you expect
even these five forces next can you
straighten up March in is there
competition other substitutes but again
at the beginning those things almost you
don't really happen very very often so
but you know something that you can make
reasonable Martin's on that's going to
grow fast that you can be the leader in
you almost always commit money I have to
say that I mean you can screw up a
traditionally but I haven't seen poor
execution and still make unbelievable
amounts of money because they will just
fit at the right time in a really high
growth growth market so here here's my
view and I actually I did this
particularly this way because I want to
point out to you that my view as an
institutional venture capitalist is
quite different than it was somewhat
different needle and would be different
if I was an entrepreneur and I think
this is you should be really mindful of
it so when I was in BC part of what you
have to do there is you know you have a
certain number of investments you have
to make to fill out your fun and you
have a you know you can only seven
somebody board so you have some economic
constraints but the law the bottom line
is that you know you have to find the
market that's going to be grow grow and
be very good and you you almost always
have to bet on something that's clever
and big at the same time that's kind of
just the nature of the game so that's
kind of what you look for and you watch
out that you're not investing too early
this this idea of you know you kind of
you want to shake out the market risk
before you do more lots of money but you
know as an angel investor I have
different strengths I can put less money
in the board and have to answer a
limited partners and so forth
so I have slightly different you know
the you of opportunities I still want
something clever but it could be medium
sized doesn't have to be
I really want something Capital Fisher
because I don't have a fund of you know
600 million or a billion dollars with
that I actually like things that are
contrarian ideas and I this is going to
sound blackness and I don't want to be
sounding negative of institutional
venture capitalist like my firm because
I think they're great miners great
they're all great but I think they often
bet blast on contrarian ideas I think
it's hard at the certainly until there's
evidence those institutional investors
remember there's a whole bunch of tape
of people around the table they all have
to sort of agree in an escrow and the
nature that is it's very hard to get
them to all agree on and try on dia if I
see something that I like I don't need
to ask him I even if it's the most
contrarian thing I say I'm in so I
actually like the Trinity is and I think
a lot of times institutional investor to
actually leave contrarian ideas to
people like me until they're proven and
then they invest in them they're not so
contrarian
but that means I get great returns yeah
can you give a couple examples sure
let's see what would be a good one um
let me give out that I'll give you some
that you know I mean I know this is my
mind but you might not know them but
I'll I'll come up with a couple that
you'll know and then the last thing I
care about a lot is a scrappy coachable
team because when I get in I don't you
know I don't have the luxury of saying
you know I'm going to write you a 3 or 5
million darts at and we'll be able to go
higher like a name-brand CEO I need
entrepreneurs that are going to be on
the job and they're going to be affected
and to I want them to be really scrappy
because we don't have a lot of money so
again you know my view has changed a
little bit when I think about
opportunities based on what my lens is
and I think again is not
this is how you should think about it -
I mean and this sort of sort of cycles
back to what we said at the very
beginning you know what what outcome are
you looking for if you want to shoot to
the moon and you know you know you
probably need something that have like
unbelievable innovation or maybe a
wildly contrarian idea but maybe that's
not maybe you want something that you
can sell for a reasonable amount of
money I was one of my choices on my
possible outcomes and you know what for
that you probably don't need to have a
wildly contrarian idea and in fact you
probably don't want a wild contrarian
idea you know you know if you want some
medium size in terms of an outcome there
you go any questions is next so what is
the other side pulls out that what is
medium-sized
well and I guess yeah what I'm talking
here is again a little bit of of what
the what the lenses of an institutional
investor in first thing and then the
second one for me but you know generally
speaking if you sell a company from
anything over 100 million dollars off
that's a common believable outcome in
most circles but frankly as much capless
that's too small you know it is in
especially capitals in the valley or
anywhere they want multi hundred
moidores so you know use of but you know
what I tell my entrepreneurs when I
invest in now is paint he'll say hey
look if we we measure our our capital in
you know it's measured in the hundreds
of thousands or maybe even one single
digit millions or maybe two two-digit
millions over multiple years we get so
the company for 25 or 50 or even 15
happy that's a hormone way that's the
kind of mentality when I tell you about
medium-sized now now again it will ya
all right so I've got other slides talk
about sort of um kind of other aspects
of this but I thought I would just take
a break here covered a lot of stuff
about you know thinking about evaluating
these opportunities entrepreneurial
opportunities so questions at this point
is none we can keep going for tada PC
Xone tend to evaluate companies whose
main motivation isn't they don't smell
on their screen so the social and these
so now they're always versus at Apple
with that there's increasingly Family
Foundation's there are some specific
venture funds that have been set up for
that like I know what one frankly but
99% of the venture capitals and all of
you probably have heard of not we're not
happening yeah how do you evaluate the
market growth and how many currently you
hear about the renewable energy
healthcare and so on but sometimes you
just want to make a list of
you can think of how do you go about
together its potential growth in the
next yeah so one of the very next things
we're going to talk about here is uh
become an expert and developing the idea
and that's where this comes out because
you know there's like big trends that
anybody can cite like you know health
care reform but what does that mean you
if you want to really look at a specific
option you have to become a super expert
on everything about it who the customer
is what the potential alternatives are
what you're going to bring the market
and that's what we do in this class that
I teach here is that the whole first
semester where we do viability research
that's what we're going to talk about
that after developing that is you know I
don't nobody knows for sure what the
outcome of any given market gross was
going to look like but I know there's a
set of questions I can ask for you as an
entrepreneur you need to have credible
answers if you don't then you've not
passed my screen as being an expert in
the area that you're trying to go to
visit so there's no there's an end
there's no substitute for fieldwork
there's no substitute for talking to
people again s what we teaches some that
first semester of the class that I teach
here you got to go out you've got to
talk to expert to get tough you've tried
it and fail you know talk to people who
you know are the customers or potential
customers that's that's where the rubber
hits the road yeah
and that's a great question so my answer
is some what what I do and I said this
earlier what I the conversation I have
with my entrepreneurs is not that a you
know I'm only investing if we sell the
company for a 50 million dollars because
you know frankly we don't know in fact
you know my attitude is like I'm my
attitude about investing is every
startup is a novel and when you first
write that first check or the
entrepreneur puts their first sweat
equity in it so it's not even the
prologue like it's like the it's like
the first letter on the cover of the
book I mean the book has so long to get
written so I don't want to prejudge the
outcomes I don't even want to limit
count I was at a like this big angel
meeting recently and there's a guy who's
of the angel investor from Canada basil
Peters interesting guy smart and this
whole thing is angels are making mistake
they should talk to the entrepreneurs
before they put a dime in they use
companies and set exactly you know how
many years it's going to be to exit and
sort of what the timeframe is and how
we're going to get to an exit and even a
little bit what the range of valuations
come to I love the guy and I give him a
lot of credit what I want to thrusight
that was nonsense how would you know I
mean if I knew right now that becoming
only worth acts in two years I probably
wouldn't invest I mean you're looking
for the upside I mean at least that's
mine and the entrepreneur to so I don't
like to try to bridge prejudge the
outcomes but the conversation I do want
to have is that we're going to stepwise
mitigate risk and take capital only to
the extent that we see the opportunity
and this is where I think experience
comes in I think this is where the clear
view of day judgment comes in I mean I
don't I'll be honest me I don't like
entrepreneurs they get all rosy colored
eyes I think that's a mistake I think
it's too easy to be
you know judge the eventual outcome by
my first 10 customer or you know good my
first two months I've got like five
thousand registered users I mean you
know we invested in frustrated they had
you know four million users and a
hundred thousand registrations like a
week but we did not make any money you
know and Twitter's got whatever you know
100 million people using it out I'm not
sure those invest okay so I think you
got it I mean who knows those are two
extreme cases but I thought I'm saying
is that I'm unweighted I'm happy to go
along with the ride but before we commit
ourselves on the big commitment for
these companies is taking lots of
capital that's the big fork in the road
once you take you can't go back so
before you make those decisions in the
light color of day with with sunshine
and all the data we're going to sit down
and really make sure we want to kind of
commit ourselves to the next week and as
long as the entrepreneur says yeah I get
I'll be happy to sell it for twenty
million I'll be happy to sell it for 300
million and take the extra risk to make
it if we agree that that's what we
should do I'm good with that
somebody's been
I would particularly go to capital
investors Apple and oh yeah will so for
example this whole idea of you know
experience file judgment about the size
of the opportunity the opportunity not I
mean I have seen a lot of scars I have
invested a lot but I've actually seen my
partners invest ninety nine them I've
been a active participant in the venture
industry now for fifteen years and you
do get a good sense of a lot so I think
there's just a lot of company building
experience and how these market evolves
and market market dynamics as well that
I think is viable Network and the very
network of people will recruiters
potential people you can hire advisers
board members investors I mean you do
all that um you know everything from
reviewing operating plans when I do all
that with my team there's no answer to
that every individual is different you
know and what I tell people who just
just blow through one of the things that
you know they tell we we tell
entrepreneurs and and you know it's
probably sort of standard operating
behavior that you check out
entrepreneurs like you call references
you know they know they're going to do
that they give you the reference tones
the first time you meet them how often
do they write back to you I say when I'm
scared like you should not take a dime
from me unless you have to check here's
here's my rest but it just blows me away
that so if you want perfectly so you
definitely want to know who your
investors are and they're not on some
you know pedestal that you you know
can't reach up with by the who they are
I mean you should and but so few people
did
you guys ever go in both for
opportunities with the company or is it
always that you're approached by
companies and how how good what the
organizational setup that allows you
knows a rock star people yeah it's all
over the map so most is to cement
capitals spend a lot of time in County
some of them actively look at certain
sectors they you know fire we had these
some off sites every year where we sort
of said Amy one of the best in this
sector in the sector and somehow we have
associates go out find everyone other
venture firms do that differently but
yeah they do a lot of outreach that said
some of the best deals are just inbound
deals that we didn't know anything about
our industry we didn't know anything
about as angels is different I don't I
mean paid employees I don't have to
invest in their deals so I sort of pick
and choose and I decide what I want so
but you know and some firms do some VC
firms do a lot more outreach than others
and some angels do I mean I know like a
some of my friends who are full-time
angels and they have reason funds in
angel funding they actually go to
conferences they put a good shingle out
saying I'm here for seed money do that
but some people do and every firm has a
different process and those suppose most
firms these days have a process by which
you can submit something electronically
and when I first got into business very
often the case but they all have
follow the questions that say you did
submit something electronically and it
was just an idea and it was kind of like
you know at first it didn't seem like
maybe like brilliant your concurring
idea where the person seemed very
obviously then all set a very obvious
and then there have the VC you say you
have your network you have your ability
of bringing the team why don't we take
this idea and build a team around it why
do we have to go with this person well
so couple things about that
what is battles never happens lets us
not mess up the business account we
investment people and their ideas not
like hey I want to steal a knight what's
the benefit of that it was really
actually a lot of disadvantages and
disadvantages of no advantages I could
think of but I think probably more
importantly one of the things we sort of
teach students in my class is great in a
compelling executive summary that piques
the interest of a venture capital sort
of that's her so they he or she takes a
meeting that's that's the goal here so
we're not to explain everything that
gets the second rule but eventually you
do want to explain everything is I okay
and my attitude is people typically way
to overvalue their idea I mean there's
somebody is that are better than others
but even then I mean communicating it to
an investor is typically not the end of
the world I mean you can keep something
in reserve this can be some secret sauce
there's still some lot of executional
stuff you have to do so I guess my point
is mine I I would tend to favor over
communication not to everybody that's
that's by the way don't miss characters
I don't like eels they get shop
everywhere there's no one if somebody
wants to talk to everybody like me every
investor on Sand Hill I think that's a
mistake there's no benefit to that I
think what you should do is have a rifle
approach where you you target the top
five investors
something about what you're doing you
somehow get into them either by saying
and really compelling exact summaries
for getting sort of sake introductions
with somebody can they know that you
know you get in front of them and you
compel them to advance
that's the waverers I mean that's what
that's the best way we're spending a lot
of time scarifying about funding I want
to make sure gets through the evaluating
part pretty much all day tomorrow
morning tomorrow stuff coming up
well I'll go through this quickly in the
next five minutes and we'll have another
ten minutes of questions okay so I
already talked to us on this but you
know the idea can come from lots of
places it can come from you know your
business experience your personal
experience research you knew it could be
even I've even heard of projects that
you know I heard a colleague say X and
then I checked it out so it can come
from Bob or it can come from something I
even mentioned here but the point of it
is when you're done you're an X I mean
up when you're done even before you
present it to somebody you're an expert
you do field research you challenge
yourself and let advisers and you know
people who you let in on the idea so
does it really make sense anymore for
the change that is necessary but you
know I wanna I can't emphasize enough
from half of the attacks I think people
underestimate that being an entrepreneur
is being you know in complete command
every aspect of starting here today
every time they're really good
entrepreneurs they can talk to you all
day long but any aspect of your business
getting yes now I'm not saying you have
to be write code and be a big marketing
wizard but anything
that's about a business that is relevant
to an investor you were going to have a
good answer on one of the things you do
is you and this is again the first
semester of the class we teach here they
have to know is you become an expert by
going out and actually doing research
you get evaluate and home the business
concept and test key assumptions you go
out in the field you can do this Deana
said earlier like talking to experts
doing customer research you know all the
things you can do to kind of identify
characterized and come up with
mitigation strategies for all the key
risks you know a lot of what you need to
do is basically field research and it
comes to all kinds of you know ways but
basically you have to get data the data
you always sort of start with with the
premise and then the data that you get
adds credibility and evidence that's the
thing that I think separates the really
good plans and the really good
entrepreneurs a lot of developers have
an idea interesting idea
but the ones that are really compelling
they have so much evidence that they've
brought to the table either by pocketed
customers or talking to experts or you
know there's so many ways to kind of
create the credibility around your idea
and that's where the research comes in
lots of stuff but I guess and I think
this comes a little bit from from from
what I see in the class I think it's
true
food a failure mode is to say I need
some money to test it out or I need you
know I need six months to test it out
and that's the value in weight gasps
hope you know the real entrepreneur they
figure out the cheapest simplest way
kind of get something out and they start
getting data and then morph it
specifically there's a concept you may
have heard in sort of that that's in the
internet store space called the Minimum
Viable Product the so-called MVP and
it's so different than when I got the
venture fund the venture business the
team would come in and they would say I
need five million dollars or I need
three million dollars and what we're
going to do is then a higher seat
engineer or 20 engineers it's going to
take this year and a half we're going to
have this beta product and then after
that we have six months of beta testing
then we're going to launch it it's going
to have all these features and they draw
up on the whiteboard this day and age
nobody gets a shepherd like what I had
when I see now what I do as an angel
investor is I want to know just the very
few minimal features that you need to
excite some customer response it may
have nothing to do with revenue and they
have nothing to do with final product I
mean nothing severe we have a very small
subset of functionality of the final
product but what I want to see is ours
the dog eat the dog food the smallest
amount of money going in and you as an
entrepreneurship sort of want to do that
with the least amount of sweat equity
going it kind of gets to the topic we
talked earlier which is you want to
mitigate the risk you want to see that
you can actually get something
before you make a lot a big commitment
and so that's where I saw say to me and
that's that's easy to think about maybe
sort of in the internet world but I
think this lesson sort of applies to
those businesses trying to get something
out to see that and mitigate the market
risk see that there is market reception
that's the success mode the failure mode
is the thing that by doing lots of
preparation and lots of work and lots of
formulation that you know someday in the
future will mitigate the market
now I'll to be clear know not every
company and not every product can go
with only $100,000 to see if it works
you know for sure you know a lot of
companies require a lot more money to
develop their products before they can
get anything back but even what if I
guys the scale whatever the scale is the
Minimum Viable Product is so it might be
100,000 it can be a million you can be
ten million it could be a hundred
whiners invest in some energy products
where they have to go 100 million dollar
plant before they know that it works I
like that kind of but you know but
whatever that minimum is don't spend a
dying more than the network so then
you've got this refinement you do your
early assessment of the customer need
and the market side you build this
Minimum Viable Product or prototype you
assess what the hidden factors are then
you go out any test you do primary
research you see if if the dogs are
eating it up to you kind of success all
that and as necessary your revised and
morph again and again some of the best
entrepreneurs you know they're the final
product or service is so different where
you focus on all is so different than
what they came in and that's just their
natural process of evolution and again I
think this this loop idea however fine
is really sort of the seminal thing that
entrepreneurs do well they are
constantly assessing where they are what
data they need and sort of feeding that
back in to improve the the opportunity
set and also specifically the out so
questions about anything we talk about
but do you actually those focus groups
or actual market research that you think
you phase it in according to the data
yet so initially it could be dirty and
cheap that's what we sort of tell people
in my class and in the real world but if
that looks good and you get some useful
funding to get it going and you build an
MVP or some prototype then you can do
more formal work so I guess the more
rigorous and the broader the better but
don't think that you have to wait around
to start getting data I don't think you
have to raise money like that's my last
my last preaching I don't like people to
come and say I don't know anything about
this but if you give me $100,000 I'll
run this task
no thank you you know do whatever tasks
you can with whatever money
that's what equity you can put it just
show me some indication that it makes
sense then we can talk about how much
money I can give you did around the next
class but don't start by saying you know
I need something to do some tasks I
think entrepreneurs again you know I
like scrappy owners but all good
entrepreneurs have to start with nothing
and the good ones go a long way even
from some market research but I'm not
afraid of non formal market research now
all right
customer feedback session MVP but one of
my fears is that because we hear a lot
of positive feedback I have this fear
that everyone's just too kind to say so
you're right to be in fear that what
just thought about the right way yeah so
that's like a Tundra met a lot of
entrepreneurs are faced with and it's
really hard to answer across the board
but I'll give you some rules of thought
about four guidelines particularly sort
of in this sort of world that I work on
internet stuff you can't gauge your
people's responses verbal responses you
can get some sense but until you got put
something out there and they actually
start playing with it
you really don't know so again the only
way in my view to do that for Internet
companies is you have some MVP out there
at CN and but here's where I think there
again there's a failure mode people put
it out there but they under invest in
the tracking so they don't really know
what happened so like I tell - BRR is
like like if you're going to spend a
dollar one product you're gonna spend 50
cents putting in some tracking because I
don't know what the answer is so I think
I think in some cases you probably don't
know if Leah tribe but there are other
tricks I mean there's more formal survey
approaches you can do and conjoint
analysis to see you know what different
leighton market needs there might be is
or triangulate
then you can do you know there's a whole
slew of research things I don't really
delve into them too much but very
sophisticated companies do so if you
want to look up that stuff you know
there are techniques for doing it does
require money and time the doctors read
what I've asked you well you know it's
such things it's not it's not general
it's very specific to the business I on
what I really I want to sort of hear
free things I want to hear that you
you've done your homework in it you're
next and so I might ask you a lot of not
even arcane questions but you know very
detailed questions like okay because I
want to know that you really think this
through the second thing I do is I
actually do look at a financial set a
financial slide or set of slide and
people say why do you that is like it's
never going to be right and it's true
it's never going to be correct but the
reason I do that is because it under it
uncovers a set of assumptions that you
have decided on or what if you have it
and I want to know what they are I want
to see how you thought about it and the
third thing is I want to talk to some
experts and this is you know the
diligence part of it I mean I want you
to tell me who should I talk to that
this is real and this is going to work
the way you think because if I find
someone who knows better than you
haven't talked that person shame on you
you need to know everything about this
and that means every acts professional
about it so those are the kind of things
I trying too late on but it really very
is specific to the idea
um well I think I would disagree with
you I think Julie in the Internet
Cerreta as I was a struggling where I
don't think talking to customers is
variable and I think talking to experts
is very viable but for example there's a
team in my class right now that are
trying is trying to do something it's
not identical at all but has some
similarities with mint and they went pop
the entrepreneur from MIT and it got a
slew of information about how they
launched it had they got free PR what
their business modeling US was and not
only what the model was but what of the
model was right and wrong
that's invaluable so when I say experts
I don't mean like like some research
person I mean someone who's actually
tried to do something similar last year
I had a team that was trying to do a
photo consumer photo thing I said you
know I know this has been tried before
go find one or two of the people who
tried it and fail because I mean they
fail and they did and it was
unbelievable how much spent on it it
didn't stop them I mean by the way again
I don't think you should be dissuaded
because people fail they could have
found because of that execution they
could have been found this is the wrong
time you know so you need but you need
to understand why they found I mean you
can't just say yeah quite sure was hell
but we'll succeed this time yeah but but
I think that when I say that so I say
experts are close but those kind of
interviews are worth a week old
not much right because if it's the
market that an analyst has our study is
probably already well understood and not
like real real startup market I'm your
real starter market there's no analyst
in story
study in fact nobody at the reason I
know that is because no one would have
paid for it and the analyst would not
studied it I'm exaggerating a little bit
well yeah but the question is you know
how how does the general so like so
that's established industry and their
new book cover
but how relevant are the the statistics
for the the work that they've done to
your product I don't know you know so
that that's the question I mean like I
remember um I've been a internet taking
minutes and around the time that I
invested I looked for a report on
internet shaking looks like five six
years ago and there was none and I
called a Forrester that typically
doesn't smell like well you know it's
all done on eBay and it's not a real
market yet so we're not planning a
market yet that's interesting they see
it's happening out there but they don't
think it's organized enough for them to
invest and I said okay I want to find
one to investment so I did but you know
so I guess what I would say is my views
typically if it's I mean I don't I don't
I don't invalidate the research but
typically if it's really well laid out
like what analysts do then it's like
what am i investing in you know I
typically want to invest before there's
a market that you can Allies now I get
in your groups a project might be a
little different but most of the times
when I invest there's no good analyst
report
as an investor
what is that
well you know hard to say but you know
there are still a lot of people in the
adventure it is free or excited about
sort of a clean tech stuff there's still
a lot of stuff going on there there's a
fair amount in you know what I would
call internet stuff but mostly around
social media you know social gaming
Facebook I mean these companies have
explosive growth a lot of interest on
that now I don't know if anybody can
make more money in that that Facebook's
already made or will make or Zynga
already made but you know there's a lot
of people fishing around that pot and
then I you know I think there's a fair
amount of stuff in the medical device
and medical health services stuff as
well but that's not an area I I look at
but I'd hear from my friends that
there's still a lot of stuff
that's a great question because I'm like
for example most people would have said
don't invest in Google it's already five
first companies and this is where it
kind of comes to the cleverness of the
idea and where the innovation comes from
or maybe how contrarian it is in other
words the contrarian idea I mean though
a lot of contrarian ideas that one of
the contrarian ideas was we're not going
to clutter up our homepage we're not
going to put ads which was the primary
revenue source of all of these existing
was putting big you know hex mini pixel
ads on the front page and the Google
product like whenever that screws up the
user experience that's a contrarian idea
it sounds subtle but it wasn't obvious
ounds obvious respect but it was very
subtle at the time so I don't think
there's anything wrong with being like a
follower but you really have to have the
conviction of your contrarian or
innovation you know contrarian idea or
your innovation and sometimes it's hard
to get funding for those but sometimes
it can be fat as a successful
and the warmer you want equipment yeah
if you you're going to recommend one
book what would be rich a favorite book
that an entrepreneur huh
should be reading thanks for all your
years and I take a trip up a book about
entrepreneurship percent or angel
investing if that's their perspective
from the lens you know I don't have to
think about that but I will I will let
you know and you can send them an email
yeah I've never been asked that question
to be honest Lee I don't think there's
many good books I've ever read about
Asperger Mary and they're probably one I
could think of if I think hard about
that and I owe you an answer to like
give you so what would be a contrarian
that well so there was one right there
Google saying we're not going to run ads
on our homepage
that was a contrarian idea that frankly
a lot of people thought were crazy I'm
not going to name who is on that first
board meeting when the founders told the
investors but that's not what they we're
going to do but some very experienced
center capitals spot that's crazy so
[Applause]
normally we're backing or at nine
o'clock there are going to be breakfast
so here